hey what's up guys mkbhd here and it is
hot today it is really hot today but i'm
here to show you a pretty cool new
product that's gotten a lot of attention
in my videos even the videos that
haven't been about this particular
product i've just gotten comments about
this product without even mentioning in
the video you've probably already
guessed it by now
i'm going to go ahead and turn around
and show it to you they've been in the
background of my videos for a little
while now and you guys have asked about
them that's right today we're talking
about the ikea audio m505 m505v2
studio monitors now some may say it's
kind of big but it's actually one of the
smallest in the range if you check out
the link in the description there's a
five inch subwoofer version that's this
there's a six inch version and there's
an eight inch version which i reviewed
earlier when i say these are powerful
i'm telling you these are powerful and
these are near field monitors so they're
actually made to be on your desk near
your ears just pumping super high
quality audio into your brain the
cabinet on these is also really high
quality and they are all magnetically
shielded so you can have it right next
to your ultra short monitor if you wish
and even have your phone right next to
it or on top of it and it won't make a
difference which is really typically
what you would do with a monitor another
plus one for these in the awesome
department is that these are internally
amplified which means you don't need
another amplifier to plug these in you
can plug them in straight into your
computer and uh both the one inch
tweeter and the five inch woofer in that
cabinet back there they're amplified so
that means you're going to get nice loud
sound power bass just accurate punchy
sounds without any sort of amplification
you see that slot at the bottom of the
woofer that's because when the base
moves there the base really moves the
air and to top it all off these are all
nice red and black finish they look
really good they kind of match the the
mouse that's also been in the background
of these videos the cyborg rat9 is red
and black and they match the theme of my
channel and i just love red and black
so i really can't say anything bad about
these studio monitors i gave the 8 inch
version the first ever 10 out of 10 i
ever gave a product review and these are
also excellent studio monitors for near
field so you can check out the
surprisingly affordable link in the
description if you want to buy a pair of
these and
that's basically it make sure you give a
thumbs up on this video if you enjoy the
sort of mini reviews that i'm probably
going to start doing more often
in between the more major videos but
yeah that's basically it review you guys
have all been waiting for right there
yeah so i'll talk to you guys in the
next video thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
you